can you hear me okay now
yes i can now thank you wonderful thank
you
i'll just say nikki before we start
please defeat
live councillor virus yeah if martin
could actually
probably contact councillor jones
because she's just contacted me
to say that she's having problems
logging in
i'll get that sorted um chair
the meeting is now live thank you
good morning everybody and welcome to
this morning's special planning
committee meeting
before we start i would like to confirm
which committee members are here
the principal clark will uh read the
role
um thank you ever so much chair so in
the meeting room uh with you here today
uh councillors william armitage steve
clough
andrew cooper mark foster lee hart
jordan
carol huckabee heather liggett
alan powell tracy reader
kathy rouse diana ruff yourself
chair of this meeting and pam windley
also in attendance today um are a number
of planning officers who will be
presenting the planning applications
today um our legal
representative um the governance team
who will be supporting this meeting
and we have richard purcell who is the
head of planning and he'll be carrying
out the role today that would usually
be undertaken by adrian kirk and the
planning manager
also in the meeting we have a number of
speakers who have all been checked in
lovely thank you as you know we have a
protocol in place for meetings in this
virtual way which i would now like the
meeting facilitator to read out
thank you chair uh this is to remind all
members
um to um to act as if they were um in
the council chamber
um during a meeting of planning um be
aware that this meeting is being
streamed
and recorded and i'm just going to start
the record button now before you'll hear
an announcement
this meeting is being recorded
um if members could speak through the
chair remaining muted
when not invited to speak if you wish to
speak
you can use the chat function or you can
raise your hand i'll be using the
captioning today and i'll put a test
across your screens very shortly
and if you've got your hand raised and i
see it to help
assist the chair i'll put a notification
across the bottom of the screen
if you could introduce yourself when
speaking so
council x representing x ward if if
you're speaking
as a ward member the voting today will
be completed by roll call on every
application we won't be doing any poll
votes
please be mindful of your home
surroundings so please appear alone on
camera
and if all planning members could keep
their cameras on at all times please
thank you chair thank you
the first item on the agenda today is
apologies for absence do we have any
yeah we've received apologies from the
following members
um councillor ross shipman who will be
substituted
by councillor windley councillor elliot
who will be substituted by councillor
liggett
um councillor barry who will be
substituted by councillor hart's horn
councillor ridgeway who um will be
substituted by councillor jones
when she arrives and councillor potts
will be substituted by councillor clef
the second item is declaration of
interest have we any
uh none have been received chair thank
you
do any members have any interest to
declare that are present
i think that's a name no that's good
item three we'll move on to planning
applications so thank you members
that moves us on to the main business
today as you can see we have three
applications each of which it has
own report marked items of the agenda
i'm happy with this and intend to
consider them in order
however before we do this i would like
the clerk to explain
for the benefit of members speakers and
the public who are watching
on youtube how they will be dealt with
right thank you chair um this is the
procedure for considering applications
at the meeting we will consider the
three applications
in the order that they are set out on
the agenda
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received
since the agenda was issued the late
items adjust
agenda supplement has been published on
the council's website
and the link to this has been sent to
members
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its youtube channel
following on from this the chair will
ask each of the speakers
any ward members first followed by
objectors
then the applicant or their agent to
speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
using the conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee
will have the opportunity to ask the
speaker questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and determination by a vote
a note for the speakers once the
application you come to speak on has
been dealt with
you may leave the virtual meeting room
if you choose to remain then please mute
the microphone
and turn off your camera you will not be
allowed to participate further in the
meeting
from that point as you're aware
this meeting is being live streamed the
council will make a recording
for the purpose of preparing the minutes
once the minutes have been propo
approved by the committee
then this recording will be deleted but
please note
that others may record the live stream
from the internet
thank you chair
thank you we'll move to the first
application which is
ned 19 forward slash 0
one two zero two forward slash fl
i'll now hand over to the planning
officers to tell us about any late
comment reports that they have produced
and for the planning manager to give a
brief presentation
showing any photos and plans of the site
the meeting facilitator will share the
presentation on screen
this means that i might have difficulty
to see everyone
therefore i will allow the officers to
complete their presentation
and ask members to reserve any points of
order
or questions about the process until the
end
there will be plenty of time for you ask
questions later on
thank you i'll move over now to the
planning officer
thank you very much chair and good
morning everybody
um if uh nichola we can have the
first the presentation on screen
please
thank you very much
this um this first application i hope
you had the first
[Music]
is as you see for a uh it's an
application for four
detached dwellings each with a detached
garage
um it's off for pepton lane or station
road
at north wingfield and you'll see the
next
google earth image on the screen
you can see the the site
is behind properties on
john's road to the north there with an
access which is an existing track
coming down from station road
next thank you
see the the site boundary there you can
see the um
location of surrounding houses
to the south and to the
west there are fields which uh the
photographs will show
to the to the north this is the layout
as shown
the um four detached houses and as you
see
there's three single detached garbages
and one uh double detached garage
and the the next
picture please is the um the designs of
the
um one of the designs of
which is um for two of the plots
and the next one
is the design of two of the other plots
and then
the garage is no surprise in
what they may look like thank you
and to this next one so
this is a a picture an aerial picture
taken from
uh many years ago to show that
the site around the time when those
bungalows at the top of the picture
there were being built
was a coal yard you'll see the
semi-detached houses
uh in the middle
there on the slightly on the right hand
side
and the uh the vegetation around there
has significantly changed as we'll see
as we
progress but really the applicant has
submitted this
to show uh evidence of there being a
uh a former use on the site
and that coal yard there is really just
to the
um the western half of the site
um and this is uh pictures of the
applicant's also shown
of what it is like now with the uh the
concrete hard stand-in
and other pieces of um the various um
areas where the coal was stored in the
wooden
uh broken areas that the broken pieces
that still scatter the site
and to the next one again other uh
pictures that the
um applicant has submitted showing the
uh
brownfield nature of the site
thank you if we go down to the next one
so this is
looking down towards station mode along
the
the track uh just to the left there
you'll see
an access which is the access to a
a small development of three houses that
is nearing completion
if we do a 180 degree turn from there
you get to
this picture
the to the left is a track that
is also the public footpath
to the right is the track that leads up
to
the site and a bit further up you see
this
you get to this point where you can just
see the
pair of semi-detached houses on the
right hand side through the trees there
uh the the con of the tree uh at the
um in the center of the screen at the
top of the track there
marks the boundary to those uh
semi-detached houses
and the the track to the application
site
goes to the left of those uh those
connected trees
the the next picture shows just off the
off the track
one of those um semi-detached houses you
can see the
conifer trees that uh pointed out
earlier and the track
then uh comes just in front of those
trees as seen on that picture
to the next picture
which is the
again the access that then will be
created
along that track there
on this side of those conifer trees
and then to the next picture this is
where
the site then opens up to
um to see the main body of the site
so just behind
your pictures on the right hand side of
the screen there you're just about to
see at the top there
a um a
the conifers that form the
eastern boundary of that pair of
semi-detached houses
and also forms the western boundary of
this application site
and you can see the um the bungalows on
john's road
behind the site next one please
so again there's a bit more square on
you can see the site um
it has been uh cleared a bit since uh
march when these pictures were taken
uh to expose the um concrete
hard standings in the middle of the site
as you see it there
the next picture please
so this is just looking from that same
position
a bit further around um you can see the
trees at the back of the
site between the site and the
houses and bungalows on um john's road
next please
again the looking at the
eastern extremity across the uh
across the site just in the top
left-hand corner there you'll see a row
of
um uh ash trees that forms the
um eastern boundary of the site
next please
again this is looking towards those ash
trees a bit further into the site
um you see a lot of bean a lot has been
self sewn
um and
under much of that under some of that
uh there's brick um big piles and
another deadly
you can see it's been naturalizing for
quite some time
so this is looking back towards the
uh those conifers um which form the
boundary to the
uh the bungalows and so this is this is
pretty much standing on where the new
road will be in front of the houses uh
the proposed houses which would then be
on the left-hand side
and you can just see glimpses of the
green field beyond the boundary
uh to the right uh to the right there
next thank you um again
um pictures of the some of the debris
that's on the site
um and the next one
and this is looking from one of the
green fields on the on the north
uh to the north of the site looking
through the the boundary of um
uh of trees there into the site
again with those um uh easily
recognizable conifers
on the right-hand side to the
semi-detached houses and the last two
uh i'm sorry not the last one this this
one is
okay this is the again just showing some
of the debris
this is on the on the side piles of
old timber and the last one some of the
uh
piles of bricks that are uh again on the
site
so that's that's a run through the um
the
application photographs the
um the application
is not within the existing built up area
of existing settlement limits for um
north wingfield um
however it should be noted that
the um significant points about
the uh the application that's is
contained in your
um in your reports one is
that in um
20 planning permission was granted
for eight houses on this site
pretty much the same layout but with
each plot having a pair of semi-detached
houses on
instead of a single house that's uh
um was an outline application but no
reserve matters
were submitted and that permission has
now expired
the north wingfield is one of our
um more sustainable uh villages
and it's considered that this site has a
um largely brownfield site which has
which is well related to um north
wingfield
and has well defined boundaries
around to around its edges to the
countryside
does represent a sustainable
site for four development um
as as things currently stand within the
policies of the um
adopted local plan and indeed the
emerging local plan the
just the other points to uh make note of
are that um there are
just to the north northern part of the
site
there's an area of grassland which
is being retained and being enhanced and
that's part of the biodiversity
offsetting
that has been agreed with the derbyshire
wildlife trust and the access
is it's proposed to
improve that access clearly parts of it
need to be actually being created
and from a far more uh
far more substantial um uh structure
rather than what's there now
other parts simply would need a a decent
surface putting on it
but derbyshire county council um
are the actual owners of the uh of the
land for the
access and so they're in a good position
to be able to
uh negotiate whatever uh surface
they feel is necessary for a development
of this type
and also serving the existing properties
there
all in all as you'll see
officers are making a recommendation of
approval
for this and in accordance with the um
all the conditions that uh the various
uh
consultees have um uh have been
recommending to us
thank you chad thank you richard
i'm now going to invite the speakers uh
to speak
as the clerk explained they will each
have three minutes
and we'll get their point across they
will be informed when 30 seconds
are remaining as members you can ask
them to clarify
any matters that have been raised but
remember your question should only
relate
to the points which have already been
made if the technology phases
fingers crossed we have asked them to
send us in advance a written statement
of their comments
these have been included in the late
comments report pack
i'm going to ask for the objectives to
speak first it's normally um
you need to confirm that your name and
that you understand the process
and that you understand you only have
three minutes to speak
thank you
right then along the lines set out in
the speak list
as as in the speaker's list yes
so the first speaker on my list
is counselor nigel barker
hey thank you chair
that's great and yeah i understand the
uh the rules and
the three minutes thanks uh and i know
this i realize this is gonna be a really
difficult one for you to
to refuse given what richard you've said
about the previous application and stuff
however i think that were then and this
is now uh and i've along with council by
ask this to come to committee
for you to have a look at and again the
local plan haven't been adopted yet but
it's a lot further on and could be given
more weight i think
and just to be clear i'm speaking today
as as the chair of the parish council
not
more more so so i'm representing the
parish really
and the parish council we're very
concerned about this development
about extending the village envelope and
and creating
another unadopted road because we've got
three down that phone lane
that as you know if you've got any
unadopted roads in your uh
they do create a lot of problems going
forward
it might be great but 20 years that line
i can see problems
especially with the length of this this
track road wherever
so i i think that there's going to be
initials with that
and i'd like to refer you to paragraph
7.4 and 7.9
because in 7.4 and richards accepted
that
it is outside the village settlement
development limit
and our concern is that this is a thin
end of a wedge as you as you're all
aware
people are trying to push the envelope
for heavy this is one development and
then
five years time they might come with
another and another
before you know it that bit doing fields
being developed
so we're concerned about that and i
believe that's a reason for refusal
because it is outside that development
limit
similarly in 7.9 i think there's a value
of judgment that
that the side it says this site provides
little
to no value to the village green field
and we'd argue we
dispute that and argue that this site
has now gone back to nature i know these
photographs are
bits of rubble and things like that but
if you go and have a look yourself
you can see and i think we alluded to it
has started to come back to nature and
and i think
it does so to flow now into the rest of
the green fields
so it would be an intrusion i believe
into that bitter countryside
i wish people could have gone and had a
look at it rather than photographs
because it gets it gives you a better
perspective of that little bit
and how it will develop again i think
that's a possible reason
for refusal they've brought back to that
uh
and the arguments are put forward i'd
just like you
to to refuse it uh and if i accept
that might be a difficult thing given
the history and everything else but
if you've been in adel you'll know what
i'm talking about that that's me chair
thank you
thank you
are there any questions
palm windly is indicating she'd like to
speak
councillor windley
uh yeah i just wondered
um has anybody ever done any
research into this area regarding the
um zigzag railway that was there
a long time ago um i believe that there
should still be
remnants of this railway there it came
down from the ling's
um curry and it zigzagged all around
and i just wondered if were they
proposing now if it
if i've ever been any research into that
land if there's still
remnants under there and i'm not too
sure if
you can answer me that question
uh i'm not that eld
i can't remember the railway line down
the incline to be honest
and as far as i'm aware it didn't go up
to that to that side
we're talking about it came down the
incline i can remember some
railway cottages at the bottom uh
and and the railway sort of then went
across the road
and joined up with mainline but yeah it
did come down the incline like you say a
zigzag
uh but i don't think it was on that
it will they the the track into it will
go on where the railway line was
definite that's i don't know
thank you thank you any other questions
thank you councillor barker will thank
you thank you for listening
we'll move on to the next speaker it's
parish councillor gail
balamore apologies if i haven't
pronounced your surname correctly
dale blameyeah and
i understand the time limit on the rules
thank you
um i'm parish councillor and resident on
station road
hepathon lane um part of the worries
about this application
is the access onto this site at the
moment it's just a very narrow dirt
track that goes as far as springfield
cottages
there is no access onto the actual site
itself as it has disappeared
over the last 20 odd years and is now
just scrub lands
what will the access actually be made of
will it be
tarmite crushed stoned because believe
me as someone who lives on one of the
unadopted roads down habsthorn lane
i know how quickly these services can um
deteriorate and who will be responsible
for the upkeep in future
our other concern is the drainage
um there's major frog flooding problems
on station road whenever there's heavy
rain the drains
on the road overflow this has now become
so bad that there are splits in the road
surface caused by the volume of water
add to this the runoff from the three on
adopted roads
that don't have drainage that flooding
at the bottom of station road just
before the bridge
and at the bottom of the incline becomes
unpossible
since the building of the many estates
below this site area
there's been the addition of a tarmac
drive road
that goes over through the stream that
runs down the incline
the flooding has become worse so the
addition of another undrained road
in this area is just going to increase
the problem on station road
and for these reasons i ask you to turn
down this application
thank you thank you are there any
questions
councillor willa b have you got your
hand up
no
nikki can you see any other hands up i
can't see many people on the screen
no there are no indications to speak
chair okay thank you very much
if we move on to the next speaker and
this is the
agent stephen haslam um
thank you chair you fully understand
you've got three minutes you'll be
reminded of 30 seconds
understandable yes chair thank you very
much
thank you thank you chair my name is
stephen haslam mitchell proctor
architect
speaking in support of this application
we have been involved with this site
since 2010 when the owner approached us
regarding the development potential of
the site
which concluded in an outline planning
application being granted for up to
eight number dwellings
the same application was resubmitted in
2014
and approved july 2015.
we picked it up again in 2019
and submitted the application before you
today for the full
their concerns which was put on the
planning portal
essentially their main areas of concern
related to the following
greenfield or brownfield councillor
barry claimed the land had all
land have been used as a brick and tile
storage distribution yard
since before
fuels up to the mid to late 1990s
[Music]
which they hope to address in
collaboration with this development
the new road and access onto station
road will be constructed to derbyshire
county council highways acceptable
standards
and shall be a positive benefit to the
existing residents along
with the new residents and should
provide a much safer access for all
users including walkers and ramblers
the proposed new dwellings will deliver
an opportunity for the smaller local
house builder and developer
which will sit happily in relation to
the neighbours without conflict
nor prominent intrusion into the
countryside
the area designated for the ecological
mitigation measures and grasses etc
will form a clearly defined boundary to
the rural
countryside preventing any further
erosion
the existing boundary trees and
hedgerows will be retained
this cycle 30 seconds remaining this
site has previously been granted consent
and again today your planning officers
have recommended its approval
we therefore look to the members present
today to support their offices by
granting its consent
thank you chair
thank you are there any questions
yeah you did mention uh that you're
gonna do
something with the roadway uh with
regard to drainage
uh but you're not really specified what
surfacing you're intending using
have you got any details on that
uh yes chair uh yes councillor we've
we've been in negotiations uh as
the pla when the planning report they
mentioned that the
lane is owned by derbyshire county
council so prior to the application
being submitted
we've had a lot of dealings with
derbyshire county council both the
estate
and the uh and the highways
and it is so it's an oakland one these
days because as you're probably fully
aware derbyshire county council highways
don't want to be adopting roads
everywhere because they
to avoid taking on the maintenance and
responsibilities what we've
provided to them is that this will be
a management there'll be a management
company which is owned by the
residents of the uh new houses and
effectively
they are they will always be responsible
for the
upkeep of maintenance derbyshire county
council
will have tied us into that in addition
they're tying us in to
the quality and standard of that road
construction
so it will be built to an acceptable
standard to derbyshire county highways
it won't be purely chatter just
rolled in as perhaps has been alluded to
so it will be a metal surface of some
description
i'd imagine it'll be tarmacked but until
we've submitted the details which we
can't go any further with derbyshire
county
until we get approval for obvious
reasons
i hope that gives you some confidence
that it will be
a proper surfaced access road
thank you councillor armitage and then
councillor foster
thank you chair good morning mr haslam
it's uh really uh just the question of
this
uh access road and uh the surface water
which has been
referred to by various people
when you say it's going to be of a
certain standard will it
be of a high enough standard to
withstand the
access of dust mid lorries
and the light because i believe it has
to be a pretty high standard to do
that and the other thing
is uh when you're doing the building
work
and what help you uh i take it
that you uh you will uh observe
uh and look after the uh the
root uh uh development areas around this
uh around the actual
uh site and you won't be damaging the
roots and
uh and rendering the trees
uh well killing them off basically so
i take it that you will be putting a
really good screen around
and maintaining it as well
thank you councillor armitage uh yes
taking
both questions quite right because
the bin lorry does go up there as it is
at the minute you'll notice within our
site we've provided a turning area for
the bin lorry
and so yes the construction of the road
has got to be too
suitable standard to meet that
those loads have been lorry i'm sure
that derbyshire county highways
as part of our negotiations with them
for actually taking
a wider strip because we're increasing
the width of the road as well to
their minimum 4.1 meters they're going
to
uh have a big say on exactly this road
they're not going to
in any way shape or form let us put just
you know
chatter down so i'm confident that the
road provided
will be absolutely fit for purpose
i take on board your comment regarding
trees we're all protective of trees
you've seen the pictures with the
hedgerows that want obviously some
management and maintenance but yes the
uh we are aware of root protection areas
and the the normal type of fencing that
you put
up around to work to keep the building
uh traffic and
construction workers away from that area
uh if i could just uh come back to you
about the access road it is a fairly
long road
access road presumably uh you'll be
putting passing places in it
is there room for passing places
that's why we've ended up
that's part of the reason why we've uh
while we're widening the road
so that there's two cars come past so
it's going to be 4.1 meters which is
wide enough for two cars to pass
the other point being on here is this
road at the junction with station road
you're probably aware for those of you
know it
is quite wide and there's another the
uh scheme that uh the case officer
referred to
earlier at the bottom that's about
finished that
their access and our access obviously
come to the same point so
it does tidy all that junction up and it
also ties in all the visibility displays
um to the front as you know onto station
road so it does actually
give quite a few benefits to a lot more
users than just
the people who we're building these for
hopefully
thank you mr haslam thank you counselor
councillor foster
thank you chair morning miss aslam uh
mine's a question
uh regarding the uh the access road um
you say there's gonna be a management
company which the residents will take
part in
we've got four dwellings there so for
property owners
um how confident are we that this will
be looked after and can you give me give
me any further details
on this management company um
i'm thinking will it be written into the
deeds of the properties that they've got
to take part in this management company
and what happens as these properties
change hands
so if you can give me a few further
details on that please
thank you councillor yes effectively
this is becoming quite a normal
procedure now on a lot of sites
where you're getting what we'll call
private roads
and the idea is that in this case we
have only got the four
dwellings so those residents sign into
they are the management company and
the the management company is assigned
various duties which will include
obviously maintenance of the road
derbyshire county council are also
involved
in that bit and we've already submitted
what we were proposing to them
they've accepted that in principle but
again until we get
we're both stuck at the moment both of
us and derby county which we can't move
any further forward
on all the details because we haven't
we're waiting for the planning hopefully
fingers crossed if we get the planning
today
we can move forward with that but
effectively
it is a legally binding contract
this with the uh with the maintenance
with the management company
so here you know the owners
prep who take it to start with sign up
and that will always be transferred down
the line so
i think it's whilst it's more legal than
i'm sort of qualified to comment on as
far as i understand it
there are plenty of these about now and
it's becoming more of a norm than not a
norm if you like
it would help obviously in the past when
the county council took responsibility
for maintenance that was ideal wasn't it
but unfortunately
people don't want any more liabilities
than they have to take do they so they
try to
avoid them wherever possible
thank you mr haslam chair would it be
possible while we're still on this
subject i know we're
asking questions of mr haslam would it
be possible to bring in
um comments from either our legal
from jim fields and or from uh richard
purcell please
would that be appropriate right now on
that same subject
i have no problem with that could we ask
for comments from them
on that subject in fact just uh
to say chair that um yes uh management
companies are
um becoming um more and more
involved with uh these sorts of
developments whether it be for the
management of uh
open space or for private loads
one thing that is has been mentioned in
the
in the report you'll notice is that of
course
um derbyshire county council will also
be able to
um uh establish in these um
negotiations exactly what level of
maintenance they
are going to require of um of
this access road
and um of the development company so
there's a lot of um
uh control they have
over this
thank you is there any comment from jim
oh there we go um yeah i mean
all i can do is just confirm everything
that stephen haslam has has said
so um ultimately um dubs county council
will remain the owner of the the
property
uh or the owner of the road uh however
they will have a covenant
with the um or with the management
company
which will will effectively be the uh
the four owners of the
the four new properties so those four
owners will have a
binding obligation um through the county
council to continue
to have a um to continue to maintain the
road
uh and if they uh if they fail to um
maintain the road the county council
will be able to take action against
uh either the the poor owners um
separately or together as as the
management company
so basically yes the the management
company is an effective
method to ensure that the the road will
will continue to be maintained
thank you thank you that answers my
question
thank you are there any other questions
thank you thank you miss haslam
thank you i'll mute myself again thank
you
are there any questions remaining for
the
principal planning officer and remember
this is for clarification
only
councilor reed is indicating she wishes
to speak to her it's all in the dark
councilor reader yes thank you chair
um i just wanted to ask richard and
richard
when there were i don't know if you know
this but when there was the um
application regarding the eight
properties before
was there similar issues coming up in
the application
in terms of when we put conditions in
place i'm sorry i don't have that to
have
that information with regards to access
of
you know to the site
um clearly this is an application needs
to be determined on its own merits as
opposed to anything that might have been
um in the in consideration for the
previous application
um i i would fully expect
that uh issues of access were being
discussed
last time and of course um last time
there were twice as many
um properties being being proposed
um but i think as far as
uh access in relation to this
application is concerned the uh
the um i can't think of any issues that
haven't been
discussed in the last um half an hour or
so
uh that um that's
what would need to be aired i think um
all the questions and um the situation
in relation to the access i think has
been fairly
very quite um well identified um
today um was there anything
particular that you you were wanting to
raise in relation to that
um uh council reader care am i able to
come back certainly
um it's just in terms of um you know
placing conditions i weren't
i wasn't sure richard with regards to
any conditions that perhaps were put
down so i know we're not
determining that last application but
obviously i want to draw on
obviously because we've had discussions
previously about that application and
access to the site and i don't believe
that we should just be discounting those
discussions because
they can assist you in making the
decisions that you're making now
so in terms of the access um you know
particularly for you know my ward in
clay cross we've had applications like
this
before where we've had we've run into
lots of difficulties
over roads that have had an unadopted
status so for me i'm trying to keep an
open mind i can see
from what mr haslam said you know that
he's trying to do all he can to mitigate
but also i'm wrestling with this um you
know
issue in my mind about what the what the
issues have been for
other unadopted roads that i've known
that have come to the forefront and
quite recently actually
so in terms of access and talking about
unadopted roads i'm just trying to make
sure
that we're very clear on what we're
accepting if it's acceptable
and if there is anything that we can do
as a council to put into our planning
conditions
to make sure that we're kind of tying
this up
and making sure that we're doing all we
can to assist those residents
okay would you like me to come back on
that joe
yes please okay um yes i think
uh i think we are putting sufficient
conditions on here
and i think that one um added factor um
of comfort in relation to this one is
that um
the the underlying
um land will remain
in the ownership of a of a public body
um as in the the the county council and
um and so there is that uh that sort of
uh
added element of um uh responsibility
that they will they will maintain on
that so
um uh yeah i i think we are putting
sufficient conditions on
on this to actually uh get what needs to
be um
uh achieved for the long term
maintenance of that uh
of that track
thank you councillor armitage
uh thank you chair uh it's really to do
with the
if we were to grant this uh could we put
a specification on
rare it is a brownfield site
uh but it's in sort of the open
countryside
uh so um there must be some
wildlife in that site at the moment
and are we going to can we make sure
there's
wildlife corridors and also
make sure that they're not the
properties are not
built tight up to the uh
the screening so the
root protection area i feel must be
uh well it must be adhered to and
policed and the same with the wildlife
corridors because
we don't want somebody coming back after
a year
well uh during construction and saying
oh uh can we fell this tree because uh
it's overhanging this garden
it won't make the house very saleable i
mean we've seen this previously
uh i mean how can we put these
conditions in
uh given the fact about the
uh uh the access role
and yes it can be made good
and made so that uh there's no wriggling
out of the conditions and it becoming a
road full of
uh potholes so the dustbin lorry people
say you know
we're not going up there so
yes uh if can those conditions be put in
and and more to the point can they be
policed
um
[Music]
on the wildlife coated on ecological
side of things
um derbyshire wildlife trust has
confirmed that all the necessary surveys
have been done
to um to
understand the significance of um of any
wildlife
in the uh across the site and around the
site
clearly this is in the overall scale of
things this is um
um not a uh a large site
that we we would normally require to
have um
wildlife corridors going through it but
the um the
applicant has already agreed with um the
derbyshire wildlife trust and
has been proposed in one of the
conditions to have
an ecological management plan that will
include the reinforcement of
retention and reinforcement of the
hedging around the site
do think that uh um to
um uh provide uh council armitage
at least and perhaps other members of
the committee as well
um with the comfort in relation to
protecting the health and longevity of
the trees around the boundary
that a root protection fencing
condition can be added to those that
have already been recommended in the
in the report um i would
uh expect that the um
ecological condition um would also
specify
the um types of
species and sizes of uh plants to be
uh to be put in to reinforce the hedge
but
um yeah if again if members are
feel more comfortable in having a
one of our traditional um landscaping
conditions
in addition to that to to reinforce that
then that too
is something which um it would be
reasonable to add to the
conditions if uh if that's what you
wanted to achieve
in granting planning permission for this
thank you are there any further
questions
i can't see many hands nikki can you see
any more oh
thank you chair uh going back to the
road again and falling on
from what councillor rita said um
about the unadopted roads uh i accept
the answers given by
the officers and i'm happy with that
uh but when we look at the actual uh
recommendations
uh and the conditions i've been reading
through the uh
the conditions up to from 1 to 19 and i
can't see anywhere there
says that um this uh
this management company must take place
unless i'm missing something there would
uh
mr percell be able to confirm that
and if it's not there would it be an
appropriate
condition to be adding to this to make
sure that permission was
granted
with that condition
over to you richard
richard you're a mute
so what we wouldn't normally do is
specify that a management company
is needed but what we would normally do
is to um
require them to submit details of the
future management of the
um of particularly public spaces
um i'm just sort of i'm just looking
through the
uh the conditions now but certainly if
um
uh if counselor foster hasn't seen
one that refers to uh the future
management of the um
of the road then uh then having a
a future management plan submitted um
can certainly be added into the um
the most relevant condition that that is
there so that's again not a um
that wouldn't be a problem to introduce
thank you councillor armitage
uh could we put a condition in that this
uh
road access road is actually
constructed before they start building
because
i can see that uh you're gonna get heavy
lorries doing deliveries ready to mix
lorries and one thing in another
and the surface is going to be torn up
and it will become a quagmire get trying
to get access up there
richard your own view
um i i take your point there and um
the the usual situation is that uh the
um
the sub courses of um of new roads are
put in in advance and
um only when it is finished because they
put the top surface on
so that uh uh it's not damaged during
the course of construction
and i i would fully expect
that that would be the way that this
development would be carried out but
um uh again um to ensure
for a number of um uh highway issues
that could be um uh incorporated
uh really for the for the benefit of um
uh existing residents who are there um
needing to use much of that um at that
track
and also to ensure that um
mud and debris is not drawn onto the
adopted highway
thank you any further questions
we can move on to the final part of this
uh
application then i'd like to thank the
officers for all their work
this leads us into the final part of the
process
our discussions about what we've heard
what we think and what we want to decide
but before going any further i would
just like the clerk to remind us about
motions
yes thank you chair uh please bear in
mind members
that emotion must be moved and seconded
before a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded
then the amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendation
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons
for doing so the reasons for moving a
motion
against other officer recommendations
should compromise comprise the relevant
planning issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject offers a
recommendation fails
on other words it's not passed that
doesn't mean
that the recommendations are
automatically approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision
through a further motion in favor of the
recommendations
or another cause of action this will
need to be approved by the committee
through another vote thank you chair
thank you um thank you for that alan i'd
now like to open the floor for debate
and again could you please refrain from
moving any motions until we have
concluded any discussion
the floor is now open
mr armata just indicated to speech error
counselor ahmed bridge yeah thank you uh
chair it uh
it's a it's like uh councillor barker
said
it is a difficult one uh i don't like
uh developments outside the settlement
development limit but
it is clearly a brownfield side this and
it's been built on before
and providing we put
all of these conditions
in the relevant conditions that have
been
mentioned i can't see a a problem with
it but
there must be adhered to and
i would move that we would
go with officers recommendations subject
to the conditions
are there any other people wishing to
speak
no thank you okay
so we have uh counselor armage is
putting a motion on the table
is there anyone to second it
counselor pal thank you
so the recommendation is that we accept
the application and as conditionally
approved no sorry i'm reading the wrong
one
it's my fault is that to grant
permission
subject to conditions foster i see your
hand is up
thank you chair uh when uh councillor
armitage mentions conditions would he be
happy to include
uh something about um
we making sure one of the conditions
could be making sure
that the uh this management company
management company is in place
could we have something like that uh is
uh are the officers
used to being able to put together a
condition like that
and could we have a an idea now what
that condition would be like before we
take a vote
thank you um yep richard is that okay
can we conclude that from from the
debate
um i am
um headlines for uh
either um amended or additional
conditions
that cover the um the management and
maintenance future maintenance of the
road
the um the route protection of the route
protection area
during construction um a
additional landscaping condition to
reinforce the ecological
condition and the construction
of the the road
to its substructure before
construction of the houses on site
starts
okay thank you thank you right before we
go any further
i'd like uh before we move the mo is
that the clerk will actually read out so
that we're all
clear what we're actually voting on yes
chair i think on the basis of that
discussion then uh the motion is is that
we approve
um officer recommendations subject to
those
additional clarifications uh which just
uh which richards just um
sort of highlighted around making sure
that
the management maintenance of the roads
is in place
uh the route protection during
construction and
um arrangements and other considerations
about ecological issues is that the
essence of it richard
sorry you're on mute
hello richard you're on mute harry yes
that's fine the um
yes that's right so so let's say the
there's the
requirement for uh details of the
management and maintenance of the road
the boot protection area uh standard
condition
the landscaping standard condition to
reinforce the
ecological condition and that the
substructure of the road is built before
work commences for the development of
the houses on the actual site
so on the basis of that chair the
recommendation is to or rather the
motion is
to approve officer recommendations with
those additional and other conditions
is everybody happy with those conditions
thank you
i now ask you to go to the vote as
explained earlier this will be done
through roll call
the principal clerk will actually
facilitate this process
thank you chair just before i move to
the vote both councillors foster and
councillor rita were indicating they
wish to speak
counselor foster do you wish to speak
thank you
i put my hand up before councillor
foster but he pretty much said what i
wanted to say
thank you hey thank you
um thank you uh moving to uh the vote
by roll call voting to go with
officer recommendations to grant subject
to conditions and the additional
conditions that have been discussed in
the meeting
if you could clearly say four against
rob stain and turn your microphone
on when i call your name counselor
armitage
four counselor cloth
or counselor cooper
or counselor foster
for hearts
huckabee
um counselor huckabee i can see you
mouthing the words for however i'm just
going to ask you to unmute one more time
four wonderful thank you councillor
jones
four castle leggett
that's a power
thank you casa reader for
casa rouse four council rough
four and councillor windley
castle windley i'm just going to ask you
to unmute
i'm just going to send you another
prompt to help you to unmute your
microphone
there you are yeah four
chair that's uh 14 votes for
the motion is carried thank you the
emotions carried thank you members
we can now move on to the next
application
which i believe is
reference number two zero four zero zero
five zero zero four slash fl
the application for the change of use of
a double garage to a beauty salon
at wellington park sherland
stuart stuart
i'd like to welcome any new um
participants to this part of the meeting
do you know there is a protocol in place
which we've gone through
so we don't really need to hit that
again so should we move
straight into the application
thank you very much chad if we could
have the presentation please nicola
thank you thank you
this application is for the change of
use of a double garage to beauty salon
at 11 wellington park sherland
next slide please eleven wellington park
is located within a residential
cul-de-sac to the east of main road
which is known as the a61
the site area is highlighted in orange
the property is within the settlement
development limit for shearland
next slide please this slide shows the
location plan
the application dwelling features a
central location within the cul-de-sac
and all of the dwellings along
wellington park are detached dwellings
next slide please
this slide shows an elevation drawing of
the detached garage before works were
undertaken
this featured a single garage door
next slide please this slide shows an
elevation drawing
of the proposed for an elevation of the
garage featuring one door and two
windows either side
next slide please
this slide shows the proposed floor plan
of the beauty salon this will contain
one main room and two smaller rooms
comprising of
store room and wc
this slide shows the block plan of the
site which identifies a single off-road
parking
space allocated for the customers of the
beauty salon to the front of the garage
moving on to the photos
this slide shows a photo of the
application dwelling with detached
garage to the side and driveway to the
front
next slide please this photo shows the
dwelling front on
and demonstrates that the driveway can
provide parking for a number of vehicles
at least four possibly five if they're
apart closer together
next slide please here the photo focuses
on the garage it is clear from the photo
that the works to the front facade have
already been undertaken
for clarity these works were done under
committed development
next slide please
this slide shows the view of the garage
which will be seen when approaching the
application site from the direction of
main road
next slide please
this boat is taken from the middle of
wellington park and shows the streets
seen to the east of the application
dwelling
next slide please
this photo is also taken from the middle
of wellington park which shows the
streets
into the west in the direction of main
road
this clearly shows that all of the
dwellings benefit from off-road parking
to the front and also demonstrates the
width
road next slide please
here the photo is taken from outside
number eight wellington park looking
back towards the entrance of the
caldistack
on the next slide please lastly this is
the photo of the
deception both the slight kid in the
road and the width of the road
thank you
the applicant is intending to operate
three days a week covering thursday
friday and saturday
the hours of use would be restricted
between 10 a.m
to 4 p.m on all three days totaling 18
hours a week
the use would be carried out by the
occupier of 11 wellington park with no
additional employees and would operate
on an appointment basis
with 15 to 30 minutes between each
appointment
there'll be one parking space designated
for the customers of the beauty salon
we've received council tea comments from
highways and environmental
health both who have raised no
objections subject to the inclusion of
conditions
officers are making a recommendation of
approval
thank you chair thank you
we i believe we have several speakers on
this
what i would ask for the speakers is
that
we can try to avoid repetition
and i will go to ask for the first
speaker which i believe
is ann brown the chair of sherland and
high and parish council
hi hey before you start you have three
minutes
and you will be reminded when there's 30
seconds
remaining yes thank you chair
um the parish council are objecting to
this
application um one of the particular
reasons for our objection
is that where this property is and those
photographs actually shown it quite well
the road narrows and it is on a slight
bend
any on-road parking would cause problems
for other residents and emergency
vehicles
and as could be seen from the photos
some residents
do park on the pavement as well which
makes it unaccessible and dangerous
for people with prams and wheelchairs
highways have been told there's a
provision for three vehicles with one
space to be dedicated to salon customers
appointments can overrun cars can arrive
to make appointments
and to see if they can be fitted in on
that day
where would these cars park obviously
they would be parking on road
or on the pavement um
also with this one other property owners
have stated that in their deeds of
covenants
that this land and properties can only
be used for residential purposes
surely that means that this application
should be refused
there are retail properties empty in the
area and surrounding areas that could
easily be used for a beauty salon
why do we need one is in a residential
cul-de-sac
affecting the lives of the people who
live there
um also
i know that there are there's no waste
storage or collection plans
surely the salon will create trade waste
this would incur an extra refuse wagon
going on to the cul-de-sac
as trade waste is collected on a
different day to
residential that is extra traffic on
that cul-de-sac
the council is also extremely concerned
and that again can be shown from the
photos
that the applicant has already started
this conversion with
builders having been at the property
their vehicles causing problems for
their neighbours
and blocking areas surely
this should not have started until this
application came in front of the
planning committee
otherwise why do we have planning rules
and regulations
and why do we have a planning committee
it's quite obvious that this applicant
has assumed
that it's going to be easy he's going to
get this permission
um apparently he spoke to a graeme
cooper and kenneth huckle
from planning and based on what they
obviously
said to him he has assumed that he will
get
permission for this building to carry on
for this business to be conducted from a
residential
home seconds remaining thank you
um i've more or less finished it's
purely that i do
hope that this will be looked into by
this
committee and that this will be refused
thank you thank you are there any
questions
i can't see any hands nikki can you no
indications to speak chair
thank you thank you mrs brown if you'd
like to
mute yourself and we can move on to the
next thank you speaker
christopher wynn
good morning good morning you have three
minutes
and you will be prompted when you have
30 seconds remaining
okay in respect to this planning
application i've sent my concerns which
like others on wellington park highlight
the level of nuisance that this proposal
will cause
all these nuisance factors are
intrinsically linked to the activities
proposed in the change of use
we have no understanding of the detail
of what the beauty salon will entail
we've since learned that children's
parties are on their on the agenda which
was not on the original application and
will not only include the children but
their parents as well
you can see the issues here increased
noise parking congestion and waste
generated
the change of use here is almost
complete and as residents we have
suffered the renovation work with
builders ins considerate parking
deliveries dust noise and trespass with
no consideration to our feelings or
concerns
mr gend has as in previous planning
application has been an economical in
providing detail to the council to make
an objective decision plausible
regarding this application
in 2012 mr gent applied for planning to
construct a two-story extension
garage which was approved as condition
three of disapproval states mr gen
was instructed to maintain a 1.8 meter
high close board defense
as both his photos show at the time and
the council state
to safeguard the privacy of neighbours
and in accordance with policies gs5 and
h5 of the local plan
this has not been maintained mr gent has
installed an open weave lattice fencing
and not completed installing this from
june 2020
where six fence panels have been left
out we have extraordinary little privacy
now
this is of relevance if mr gentle has
left these panels out to assist in the
conversion of this silent development
it aids his builders and the proximity
of the garage is so close to the
boundary they cannot access it
with the fence panels in place as part
of the application in 2012 mr gent
stated that the garage would be one
meter away from the boundary
so he would have no requirement to
access the neighbor property
the actual distance is possibly 30
centimeters is its widest point
all these issues are causing significant
concerns around my own families
my own and family's mental health and
well-being these are underlying stresses
which can ultimately
initiate anxiety and health problems
privacy is an important issue here
central to our own human rights and one
which will be significantly affected
should this
application be approved i think there is
merit in drawing your attention to the
approved application in 2012
as the conditions have not been complied
with as stated on previous applications
to the detriment of neighbours from
wellington poll seconds remain
so what assurance can we have that few
future cons
conditions will be adhered to and who
enforces these conditions when they are
clearly in bridge
thank you thank you mr winn are there
any questions
can you see any hands up that i can't
nicky no questions chair
thank you thank you mr win we move on to
the next speaker
a madeline map
good morning you have three minutes and
you will be prompted at 30 seconds
remaining
i refer to the written application from
mr gent together with comments he has
submitted himself online and in letters
to neighbours
where he states that his current partner
tanya will be running the salon
in that application at number three he
states that the garage door replacement
will be the same as the house
it is not at 14 he writes that the
garage is being used as storage
this admission is clearly a breach of
conditions imposed in 2012
and planning applications conditions
stated should be used for the parking of
a motor vehicle only
and not for general storage on the 10th
of july
highways recommended spaced out
appointments
to avoid multiple customers being on
site at any one time
on the 15th of july i objected to this
raising concerns of safety to residents
due to the number of extra vehicles on
the road
this is based on the fact that tanya is
already running a local salon
and on her website has over 650
photographs
of children's makeup parties which
include up to nine
children at a time the following day mr
day
mr gent responded online to say that
children's parties
will always be car share only
he is obviously totally disregarded
highways recommendations
and intends to pursue parties resulting
in several cars
at a time delivering children how he
thinks they can enforce
car share conditions on parents is
inconceivable
neither could the authority enforce any
such condition
just imagine all those parents
congregation and talking
and blocking our road mr gent has not
mentioned
or amended his application to include
these parties
a significant admission in my opinion
my office lounge and bedroom are
directly opposite this eyesore of a
converted garage
that is definitely not in keeping with
the rest of this road
every day i witness inconsiderate
parking by residents and visitors to
number 11
parking on the pavement across the
pavement as in my photographs i've
submitted
and directly opposite a service fan we
had recently
leaving no room at all for large or
emergency vehicles to pass
every day i see children playing
children visiting their grandparents
grandparents visiting their
grandchildren wheelchair users walkers
runners retirees one in her eighties
using this road and having to use
seconds remaining
often they have to bypass vehicles which
have been abandoned on the pavement
outside number eleven
extra vehicles will simply aggravate
this situation
it's not part of an estate it's not a
busy road
it's a safe place to live and it should
stay that way
thank you
thank you are there any questions
thank you and the next speaker is a mr
john
map i assume mr map does want to speak
okay um we'll move to the next speaker
then
no no no he does yes yes
you have three minutes mr map and you're
reminded of 30 seconds remaining
yes thank you very much we are here to
discuss the proposed application
the problem is the alterations in the
garage have been fully developed by the
applicant
prior to this meeting there are 21
residential homes on wellington park and
on the portal there are 16 objections
but not one in support this shows the
community feeling towards this
application for change of use
it is unnecessary and unwanted
development of the residential property
into that of a business they will have
big this
will have adverse effect on the
character and style of the properties on
this small
residential cul-de-sac which is contrary
to
nedcc gs7 and
h12 local plan there is a suitable
vacant commercial property in the
village within 250 yards
i live directly opposite number 11 and
my daily life
and privacy has been interrupted by and
will continue to be
interrupted if this salon opens
our properties are at the narrowest part
of wellington park
parking has always been an issue more
traffic
and more parking outside number 11 will
become
an ever bigger problem to me and my
neighbors
as we try and drive on and off our
properties
the applicant states there will be one
customer at a time
and an allocated parking space on his
drive
the applicant has three vehicles parked
there every day of the week
i can categorically say that it is
extremely rare to see
more than three cars popped on the drive
has his rig
as his regular visitors generally parked
on the pavement the drop curve at number
11
is narrower than the drive itself as can
be seen by photographs already submitted
the applicant cannot control where
clients will park we all know people
will
park where it is easiest to overlapping
appointments
created by those that overrun and those
that arrive early
will create parking problems
there are 48 vehicles living on
wellington park including those from
properties on main road
plus visitors delivery and builders
vehicles
as the residents continue 30 seconds
remaining
wellington park will become very
congested
everyone on wellington park including
the applicant
has signed their deeds which state that
properties
are to be used for residential purposes
only
we have to abide by these legal
documents and show you should the
applicant thank you
thank you are there any questions
no we can move on to the next speaker a
janice price
it's janine price actually
hello everyone
hello janice you have three minutes and
you'll get a prompt when 30 seconds is
remaining
thank you but it's janine
you'd like i'd like to say that when the
applicant who is a wheelchair user
originally applied for permission to
extend number 11
he informed planners that a double
garage is required that so i am able to
park my car in the garage
with enough room to get out of my
vehicle and access the house from within
the garage
when we experience bad weather and snow
i find it very difficult to maneuver
outside and a garage makes it possible
for me to use my vehicle to get around
i'm also aware that the pros proposed
development directly contravenes
established and agreed deeds of covenant
for the homeowners on wellington park
which specifically state that all
buildings are used for private and
residential purposes only
it's already clear that building and
construction work has been ongoing for
several weeks
in itself creating parking problems
caused by contractors
that highlight the detrimental effects
of street parking at a restricted
narrow point in the street which causes
access issues
to neighboring properties and other road
users
the restricted width of wellington park
outside number 11
means there's no on street parking
unless vehicles are parked partly on the
pavement
the nearest available on street parking
is on the a61
which is already narrow hazardous and
heavily congested
the applicant states that parking will
be on their drive
but current practice demonstrates that
visitors to the property
already regularly park on the street
causing an extremely
narrow pinch points
and making access to and aggressive and
properties lower down
very difficult and i think there's some
committee you've got access to some
photos that have been provided by
neighbours
last year this committee turned down
permission to convert a garage to a
business on fernley in sherland
due to the application being likely to
and i'm going to quote here
significantly increase
the demand for parking in a relatively
narrow cul-de-sac
to be likely to cause an instruction
obstruction to the free flow of traffic
to restrict or obstruct access to
private driveway driveways
and obstruct any larger vehicles from
safely using the street
this request was for a child minding
business for i believe the maximum of
three children
the applicant's girlfriend has already
told residents that she'll be running
parties for up to nine children at a
time
at this point seems to be narrower than
firmly
the proposals are also out with any
considerations of any form of
consultation
in the neighborhood plan or the effects
of a change of use within the street
on the value of properties when the
council has already
had information to suggest there are
issues with relative values of property
in the north east derbyshire area the
proposed business use of the premises
is not in keeping with the residential
nature of the street
wellington park times a small
residential culture back
which consists of just 22 family homes
the majority whom are on records of
rejecting to this
please consider our views and refuse
this application
thank you
mic isn't working
uh just bear with me chad i'll try and
oh i've just pinched counseling [ __ ]
um thank you are there any questions
no questions from members chat no thank
you
can we move on to the next speaker
please and i do believe
that is mr bruce swift
uh yes chair mr bruce uh swift
is unable to attend today so if you just
bear with me a second
we'll actually read houses text for you
um
okay thank you and it starts from now
i would like to object to this
application on several points
first wellington park has a large
proportion of families with young
children
as a close it has always enjoyed a
relatively quiet and low
traffic environment many of the children
including my own play together outside
in what is considered to be
a safer than average space however
it is not a through road therefore
any visiting selling customers will have
no choice but to continue past number 11
and then use the close as a turning area
in order to exit
the increased traffic clearly represents
a safety issue
to all residents but especially the
children
second the applicant claims on of air on
available parking spaces for customers
at number 11
is misleading realistically the maximum
limit
at number 11 is four vehicles at best
which would clearly have to include
their own cars and those of any
additional
staff they may hire in the future
also the applicant himself is wheelchair
bound
and cannot move around the parking area
without adequate clearance
a point he was very keen to focus on
when he submits his original planning
application for the double garage
in 2012 third
a commercial property simply wouldn't be
in keeping with wellington park
and the surrounding area and fourth
the applicant clearly ticks the box on
his application
to state that work has not started this
is untrue
not only has it started but it is almost
complete with such a clear disregard for
planning regulations
the issue of trust regarding the
promised use
and any future use expansion should be
taken into account
that's the end of the statement chair
thank you
thank you and we move on to the next
speaker
which is in prague no sorry i've jumped
one
rebecca parker
good morning good morning you have three
minutes with a 30-second prompt
thank you thank you wellington park is a
cul-de-sac with properties inhabited by
mainly young families
and those of retirement age with
grandchildren
the children play currently out on the
street on bikes and scooters and
although there have been on social
parking
issues we can rely on the majority of
motorists and residents
so to be residents or family members so
they have a
amount of awareness about children
playing out having a salon open on the
street will increase the traffic putting
our children in danger
as clients will not have the forethought
to expect children to play whilst
visiting and obviously
when they obviously expect a business
premise
the salon will be open when the children
return from school
and for six hours on a saturday the
opening hours will also affect the
children over the summer holidays when
we try and get them out to play as much
as possible
i feel this would be extremely dangerous
given the young people being unfamiliar
with the street
will be arriving for their appointments
with the possibility of children's
parties being held at the salon this
will increase the number
of vehicles arriving on the street at
the weekend making it even more
dangerous
reversing off the applicant's drive is
difficult
as it's lower than the road so
visibility is minimal given
the property is also on the inside of
the curb of the road
this is also the narrowest part of our
caldisak
the salon is direct directly opposite my
house
and we will suffer loss of privacy which
we do already with builders
and due to the arrival and departure of
customers meaning our french
lounge is unusable with the amount and
volume of traffic
also reversing off our drive has been
difficult given to
parking issues at present and the added
vehicles to and from
salon will cause extra difficulties
we purchased our property with the deed
of covenants in place stating no
business should be run from
this residential property any of the
residential properties
this is to protect our neighborhood our
environment and ultimately the safety of
residents and their children
there is are many vacant commercial
properties
in the village and the local town at the
moment this is ideal for businesses of
this
size with parking and the possibility of
passing trade that would not impact
this street and its residents
the applicant for the business the
application for a business
on a residential street is unnecessary
and damaging to the safety of all
residents and particularly our children
our home should be our sanctuary not a
business place
thank you very much for your attention
thank you
are there any questions no
thank you rebecca moving on
moving on to our next speaker ian
thank you chair have you three
i understand my limitation in the three
minutes thank you
like many other people that have already
spoken i'm objecting
to this development on the grounds of
safety for
primarily the young people and the adult
residents
of our road i've lived here for over 19
years and during that period of time
my children have grown up and now my
grandchildren
are growing up often playing with
neighbors children
in the road in a relatively safe
environment
the development as it's been outlined to
you will include opening
on weekends at a time when children are
off school and likely
to be playing in the street the
additional vehicles coming into this
street not knowing the nature of the
street
and not knowing that increases the risk
of accidents
and accidents have already occurred
within this street in the last two years
also what's not been mentioned is access
for emergency vehicles for elderly
members at the bottom half of this
street
it would not be possible on weekends at
the present time
on occasions because i have a motel
myself for full access to the street
and i worry that the increased
congestion
would exacerbate this i would point out
to members
making decisions today that the planning
officers
photographs were clearly taken during
office hours on a monday to friday
and were not taken during evenings or
weekends
where there is a large amount of traffic
parked on the side of the street
and i'd also concur with the other
objectives
in that i'm aware the council has
already refused planning permission
in a similar residential building on a
similar cul-de-sac
up firmly due to the potential dangers
in traffic i suspect that the lack of
objection from the council
has been because they have not visited
the street
prior to responding to the planning
application
thank you chair that's all i wish to say
thank you very much
are there any questions
no questions chad thank you we'll move
on to the next speaker
uh yes chair that would have been a
kevin gutterson who unfortunately will
not be able to access
um the uh the meeting today however we
have the uh text of his statement which
i'll now read out
thank you okay i write to express my
objections to the change of use of a
double garage to a beauty salon
on the following grounds the deeds of
covenant to our property
restrict all buildings present and
future to private
use only i have liaise with some
neighbors
and those are the same the proposed
change of use
is not in keeping with the residential
nature of the cul-de-sac
and would encourage additional vehicular
and parking issues
the applicant states that there would be
a dedicated parking space
on their drive as you approach the
property from the ac
as you approach the property from the
a61
is a low wall to the property which
would make it impossible to see the
dedicated parking space
this would encourage roadside parking of
pavement parking
the highway outside number 11 is not
only curved
but also narrow and already makes it
difficult
for two vehicles to pass to have to
contend with potentially park vehicles
in that area
uh two would be a cause of concern
there have never been so many young
children living in wellington parkers
now
and the proposed business will increase
traffic to the quiet cul-de-sac
resulting in potential safety-ish
concerns for the children
the applicants has stated on the
planning application form
that work has not started this is not
the case
the front facade of the garage already
resembles the proposed elevation in the
application
and it is also clear that work has
commenced internally
this is very disappointing that the
applicant has gone ahead
without the concerns about the planning
process or the views not only of the
neighbors
but of the local community too
there are empty commercial properties
within sherland that would be more
suitable for the nature of the business
intended by the applicant
it is distressing that having lived on
the residential cul-de-sac for 20 years
we now find ourselves in a situation
where this could be totally transformed
with the proposition of a business
property and the precedence this may set
for future applications of this nature
and that is the end of the statement
chair thank you
thank you and we move on to the next
speaker
lynn shelton
hello hello you have three minutes with
a 30 second prompt before you finish
thank you thank you our objections
mainly are parking
the cul-de-sac is narrow and is already
subject to difficulties due to
inconsiderate parking
and parking on pavements the planned
application will undoubtedly increase
these issues and also pose an
increased safety risk despite mr gent
expressing that there are five parking
spaces on his drive
and the customers will park on there we
all know in reality that just won't
happen
the cars will end up parking at the top
of the road which is opposite our house
and due to how the houses are numbered
it is likely
that the cars will drive down the road
turn around in the bottom and then come
right back up to the top
we've suffered recently with parking
issues due to the building
of the houses on the main road with
builders using
the road as a car park and it makes it
extremely difficult due to the bend in
the road and how narrow it is
to pull on and off our drive and others
as well
if cars are parked at the top of the
road either
on both sides or either side it could
cause a hazard when turning into
wellington park off the main a61 highway
in addition any additional parking poses
an increased safety risk to the young
children resident on wellington park
who play outside serious attention must
also be given to the risk that
emergency vehicles would not be able to
access
houses at the bottom of the road mr
gent's household and visitors
up until recently and that is since this
application has been made
typically park on the road and also
completely on the pavement
if approved it's highly likely that this
approach will resume
and next thing deeds of covenant or
residents on one of the park of
restrictions in their deeds one of those
is that the properties are residential
only
if this application is approved it will
set a precedent
for anyone else on the road to be able
to disregard any of the restrictions
i completely understand that given the
current coverage situation we are
encouraged to work from home
however that does not mean set up a
business in a residential road
thus bringing more people into contact
with residents
what we should be doing is consider
businesses to be set up in our local
towns to attract life and custom
into our um into onto our
high streets because they're in danger
of seconds remaining
we all have a duty and obligation to do
that
um it's totally not in keeping and also
of a serious concern is that the work
has been completed without planning
permission
which is a total disregard for
neighbours legislation planning
processes
and the planning committee thank you
thank you are there any questions
no questions chad thank you
we'll go on to the final speaker which
is the applicant
glenn gent
mr gent are you there hello yes
hey you've got to fight with yourself
tanya west my partner will be reading
the statement if that's okay
that's fine ok
you have three minutes starting now
thank you
we have two main reasons for wanting to
convert our garage and for me to work
from home
the face is that we would like to start
a family together
unfortunately we have to go through ivf
which we are starting on the 2nd of
october
i have already endured losing a baby at
25 weeks
i feel working from home with less hours
would definitely be a lot less stressful
the whole process as you can imagine is
very stressful and will put a lot of
mental and physical strain on us both
glenn is also wheelchair-bound so me
working from home
would benefit us both massively as as
glenn
would really struggle to look after a
newborn baby on his own and it would
allow me to help him around the house
with daily chores
our second main reason is that as you
are all aware we are in a terrible
pandemic which is hugely affecting
many small business which includes mine
with increased
increasing rent and overheads having
less clients
in the salon due to covered cleaning
regulations it's becoming more of a
struggle for my 12-year business to stay
afloat
there is now a large amount of people
working from home in spare rooms
summer houses and garages which is being
advised by the government
due to the chronovirus where i currently
work
it's a room that i rent above a hair
salon
with four stylists downstairs i
i would feel safer as with my clients
not having to pass all this
to come upstairs being at home in our
converted garage would mean it's only
ever
one to one we both feel that the 18
hours part-time we have applied for are
very reasonable and wouldn't affect our
neighbours
commuting to and from work we do have
enough parking on our drive for five
cars
and there would be a designated space
for the proposed beauty salon
which would not cause any disruption to
our
i'd also neighbours to point out that
there have been many assumptions made by
our neighbors
which include me held into children's
parties
which is not something that i've applied
for and also i will not be hiring
any employees we would also like to
say that the covenant which we have seek
legal advice
from elizabeth kingsley's visitors
that the deeds are 21 years old
and said our builders darba limited who
put the covenant in place
dissolved in 2018
one more point i would also like one
more point i would also like to make is
the waste collection
i have never had to have a specific
waste
collection at my salon and glenn uses
catheters
so we already have hazardous race
collection every tuesday
from our home and have done over the
last eight years
you thank you are there any questions
that's the tracy reader's indication she
wishes to speak
counselor reader thank you chair
i just want to ask um the applicant
um you've alluded that you wouldn't be
having children's parties but within our
report
it does say with children's parties in
the section
where it says support that children's
parties it will always
be a car share only and only the
birthday child's parent
is allowed to stay during the party
so could you just clarify with regards
to what you've just said
will you be intending on holding
children's parties or not
yeah with the obviously current pandemic
and not being able to have
um more than six people being together
i'm not going to pass that and obviously
i do want to keep
the cars and the traffic to a minimum so
no
it's not something that i'm going to
apply for it will just be
one client in and a pacific cleaning
time between each client and one client
out
thank you are there any further
questions
no further questions chair thank you
we now have the opportunity to put any
questions to the planning officer
and please remember that they should be
focused
on getting clarity for any points that
have been raised
thank you uh councillor liggett
can i just have it clarified would the
need trade waste
bins or not
i think you've heard from the the
applicant
um about uh about that um i don't think
really we've got anything more to
to to add to it but um
so far where she has been operating her
business
she hasn't had a need for um for trade
waste
and because of personal circumstances
they do actually have
a specialist waste collection um
already that uh that comes from the uh
from the house but um
i don't think we have any additional
information that we can we can add to
that
thank you any other questions answer
tracy reader
counselor house you're mute
sorry i was listening then obviously the
lady tania she
she mentioned something about the
builders which resolved the covenant in
2018
i wonder if richard could actually sort
of explain
how that would be because obviously but
everybody that's spoken has actually
spoken about the covenant
of keeping it residential rather than a
business
well as is uh often the case um
on planet applications that we we
discussed that
um you know clearly the planning
decision
relates to planning issues and um we
can't
give any weight one way or another in
relation to
existing covenants um whether
um the council is jim fields and wants
to
mention anything about the significance
or
lack of it in relation to the builder no
longer being in existence to be able to
enforce or to relax that uh that
covenant is so
it's another matter but as i say it's
not a um
a planning issue which we would uh be
able to give any weight on one
way or another thank you richard it was
just for my clarification that was all
you want me to comment yes please
yeah i mean i mean it's hard for me to
uh to
provide detailed advice but um
the if the um the person who has placed
the covenant
who plays the covenant in the in the
first place no longer exists
it is probably an unenforceable covenant
unless that person has transferred the
the rights to enforce to a
to further party um the the applicant
has stated that she's taking legal
advice and the legal advice
is that it would be um unenforceable
um but as richard says this
it is an irrelevant issue in in terms of
planning because
enforceable rights legal rights is not a
material consideration
thank you councillor reader
thank you joe i just wanted to ask i
don't know if it's best aimed at
jim or richard but um
i was just wondering if there was any
possibility of
of adding into it into the um
conditions um for accepting
accepting the uh you know the
application
yes i recognize that we're in a pandemic
at the moment
you know in years to come this
application
will obviously still be standing there
hopefully years
in the future when the pandemic we
finally got through it and through the
other side
um what i would sort of want to see
protected is obviously to
keep the residents uh happy as well
which is that we're not gonna go into
this situation where
the restrictions are lifted and then all
of a sudden we're ending up with
lots and lots of people turning up and
parking on the roads
and creating a general nuisance so i was
wondering if
it is a possibility to put into the
conditions
um limits on the amount of of customers
that are turning up
at the property i wasn't sure if we were
allowed to do that
over to you gentlemen
um yeah i'm just looking at the
conditions that we do
have there um but there's a
um a limit to the hours that
are proposed on the thursday friday and
saturday
there is the um the limit
to having a clear 15-minute
to 30-minute gap between each customer
which is to ensure that um a
uh one customer's car has
uh has gone by the time a new customer
arrives um
i i think if if you're
if you're suggesting that there's only
one customer at a time
um yes i mean that that is a a
a condition that can be added that
there'll be no more than one customer at
a time
i mean clearly you know from time to
time
there may well be a a parent that
is is that not sorry um shall i
get clarification as to the the point
you're raising council leader
where am i allowed to come back
certainly
so the concern for me is at the moment
we are in a pandemic
and the applicant has said that during
this pandemic she wants
obviously to keep it very safe and i
recognize
that but at the same time hopefully in
years to come we're going to be out of
this pandemic
and the residents are raising lots of
concerns
around parking issues now i get i'm a
parent
you know i've got children i'm going to
want to attend
um a haircut or something with my child
that's going to happen
and i think most people would find it
acceptable
that you can have one car turn up to
to drop that family off and there's been
one parking space that's been allocated
in the application for that
but my concern is if we were to
not sort of because at the minute in our
report even though the applicant is
saying no children's parties and things
like that
it is still written into this report
about children's parties car sharing and
things like that
and i'm concerned that in years to come
when the restrictions are lifted
that we're going to have problems with
perhaps
uh residents being put out because of
lots of people turning up and that
potential that this application has gone
through
that still stands within this report and
then we're going to end up with lots of
children's parties going on
and things like that so in order to give
the residents some comfort as well
what i'm asking is can we restrict the
amount of customers
that turn up at this property to make it
safer for the residents and give them
their immunity
whilst also offering the applicant the
opportunity to have
a business
yeah the the conditions they are
proposing here
would stand with the um the property and
with the
um the business regardless of where we
are
in a particular um
covid cycle and whether we're through it
or whatever so
so they would stand um i was referring
to an additional condition
that might um uh
deal with what your uh concerns were
about um numbers of people turning up
at a time so having a condition that
shows there should be
no more than one um person
um with or without a dependent child
it's another matter
one one one customer at a time clearly
the title of the application
is for this beauty salon the proposal
as outlined in paragus 2.5 to 2.8
all relate to that i think that
if um they are
uh running and offering their uh house
as a base for um children's parties
that is something which we would need to
monitor to see if that
in itself was a um another element of
this business
um clearly that's been mentioned as part
of the
um letters of support but the
application
was to what this application is about is
is very clear
could i have some clarification from
legal on that and then it will be
counsellor foster
yes so just could you clarify what what
specifically you want clarification on
just
can we actually add that this
restriction will be put in place
and it cannot be changed
i i don't see any uh any problem with
placing a suitably worded restriction
uh and if if they wanted to
to change change that which
reduction they would have to make a
further application at certainly at the
appropriate time
i think any restrictions that that are
in place will will remain
thank you councillor foster
thank you chair uh uh i'm glad you're
serving uh being cleared up this
business with the
the leases or rather the covenants uh
when it comes to what you can and can't
do at a residential property
it's also i believe the same with
mortgages uh as well
and i understand we can't give any
weight to this i think that's why
without going into a discussion this is
a this is a question
um i think that's why it's down to us
and we have a duty to care for the
health and well-being of residents
um in situations like this so my
question is about the pandemic because
it's been brought up a couple of times
now
by the applicant and by councillors uh
do we put and it's a question to
um to our planning officer
do we put any weight at all onto this
pandemic
at all when it comes to planning
considerations if we can put that to bed
please
as i say the um this application is
being considered and these conditions
that are being recommended
would be applicable um for
regardless of where we are in relation
to a pandemic
um the the conditions will be there and
will be enforceable
um and for for now and forever
unless there any future variations that
are applied for
but that's something within the scope of
the authority as as we're all
aware that occasionally comes for a
decision but
um these these conditions and this
application
um regardless as to whether or not it's
found to be convenient
for the applicants at this point in time
to or additionally convenient for the
applicants at this point in time to
who wants to work from home because of
uh um
covid restrictions this um
uh planning application the
recommendation and the conditions would
stand
regardless of covid i thought as much
thank you
thank you councillor liquid i was just
going to have something very similar
about the restricted hours the 18 hours
um is that to continue and also is the
council in position
to enforce those hours
the um
those hours are fairly um definitive and
um quite easy to enforce in terms of um
there will be many watchful eyes over
what is going on
here if consent is granted to know
whether there are
um hours of operation breaches
um i'm sure we'll be told um
very regularly um and uh
there will be uh passive monitoring um
within the
um within the cul-de-sac and then
clearly if there
is a breach of that then there are um
uh two ways of uh um of us taking active
monitoring of that one is
by monitoring the situation ourselves
um by visiting the site some particular
hours either before or after
um and indeed for um looking at
uh other evidence that it may be in
relation to booking
bookings with the applicant or what has
been advertised on site
on websites
are there any further questions
thank you again same rules apply
um we can open the floor now for a
further debate
or if anyone has a motion they'd wish to
help counselor reader
counselor foster um
as i've already alluded to i i do have
concerns
that we might be in a position at the
moment
obviously we have got government
restrictions in place
but i just want to kind of highlight to
everybody my concerns
yes i recognize that in in in the report
itself it's got the limited
hours per week which will you know you
restrict
the amount of time the business is
operating for
but i do have concerns about the
potential
in the future for more customers to be
turning up at a residential property
which could create traffic issues and
safety issues around the estate
so i would would like to sort of suggest
that we put something in there
that that makes it a bit more clear
that we're not going to be having sort
of six to nine children or parties
turning up at this property
thank you we could always put a further
condition in
to um restrict parties within the beauty
salon
thank you councillor foster uh thank you
chair
uh for myself if we're on to the debate
and now
um the property is located in a
residential area
as we know and it's where occupiers can
reasonably expect a level of amenity
that comes with living in such an area
and that's why the original leases and
the mortgages that people would have
taken out in this area
that's why they're there in the first
place uh that and together with what we
can do
um the use of number 11 as a business
introduces a diverse element that would
likely result in noise disturbance
and a nuisance to the detriment of
residents
and in my view to the health and
well-being
of those residents when it comes to
policing them
uh afterwards and enforcing uh anything
i think i think it's it'd be
extremely hard for anything like that
so for myself uh it impacts on the
character
of the area it is a rental residential
area and it's not in keeping
where with the area and when you read
which i'll perhaps come onto these later
i'll come back on these
but when you look at the uh the
restrictions
the the reasons for refusal that were
given for seven
fairly if uh if councils have uh looked
at those
uh those apply quite equally in my view
to this case it's a residential area and
it's
this is how this business is out of
character with the area
so that's my view thank you councillor
pal
thank you chair um this is clearly
a lovely residential street i wouldn't
mind living there myself to be honest
and the imposition of a commercial
premises only to me
it would have an impact if we look at
the policies that have been quoted in
our report
um if we look at gs7
um it states that planning permission
for change of use will be committed
provided the use scale and type of
operation will not have an adverse
effect
on the character of the area and
neighboring land issues
well i think it will have an effect on
the character of the area
and if you look at local plan policy e8
that change of use and extensions to
existing sites
will be permitted provided that the
proposals do not have
an unacceptable effect on the character
of the surrounding area
through visual impact noise or pollution
resulting from the development
of traffic generated now i think that's
that's exactly what will happen but it
does have
it does have an impact as uh foster has
suggested
um and the other point i would make is
that um
the uh the as i was outlined in seven
six of the report emerging
policies within the publication draft
including policy ss7
um this support this policy is
supportive
of development provided is of a scale
and design
that would be in keeping with the
character of the surrounding area
and again i think that is what we can
say is that it would have an impact
and it's a it's a quite residential
street
and i i think i think we should reject
this application
thank you are there any other comments
counselor foster
i think council armitage was before me
i'd be happy to follow council heritage
i didn't see his hand councillor
armitage
[Laughter]
thank you chair uh i
uh i looked at this and uh
the uh a lot of advice on my wife
and my wife uh uh had
for a well a large number of years her
own salon
and i asked her about uh hours that
they're going to be working
and she said well you just depend she
said you can't
uh say if one treatment
takes so long or and in any case
uh she said that uh you know some
treatments you know you may book
somebody in and it's
uh you know the average will be an hour
and she said it could easily run over
and so that's the thing i was looking at
is the fact that uh the parking
problems are going to be there uh and
there could be more than one uh vehicle
uh in a street which doesn't uh
well can't facilitate it uh
we've had arguments about uh
uh traffic but we all know that
everybody's buying online at the moment
so they'll be
increased delivery vehicles as it is
but uh the
work has started and but
in the uh application he said it
uh that the work hadn't started
now has it or isn't it as far as i can
see
is taking place and the other worrying
thing
there's only one entrance into that
garage and there isn't one out at the
back
and they're using some of the materials
acetone and whatever
uh it couldn't you know it's a fire risk
and you need to get out
fairly quickly perhaps uh
councillor foster is more qualified on
things like that
but i can't see you know
we've got to be consistent with what
we're doing and
uh the application that was turned down
on fernley
was uh well it was uh it would mirror
this one
you can't say that the fun that the
pandemic
hopefully is going to be finished a year
at the most
and you can't make uh up you know
uh assumptions it's going to be here
forever
but the uh when you pass something
on uh uh planning it's here forever
and it's not a deal you can do against
it
so the pandemic as far as i'm concerned
uh won't wash in this particular
case the other thing is uh she's already
got a salon
it isn't as if we've been pushing around
uh
of a salon or she's uh anything like
that
and okay we work from home a lot of
people are working from home
as we are doing in this meeting at the
moment but then
it's to do with the pandemic and as i've
already reiterated
it's not going to be here forever but
planning regulations
uh have to be and that's just my
point thank you councillor foster
thank you chair uh if i go too quickly
the reasons given
uh to refuse permission for
uh seven fairly if uh if i'm able to
read these out
it says no adequate provision is
including the application of proposals
for the parking and maneuvering of
vehicles clear of the public highway
which would be likely to result in a
significant increase in on-street
parking
on uh fentanyl causing obstructions
or parking on the shared driveway
leading to obstructions and ownership
maneuvers to and from the public highway
either scenarios against the best
interest of highway safety is likely to
lead to potential danger and
inconvenience to other highway users and
interfere with the safe
and efficient movement of traffic on the
adjoining highway uh
like councillor powell says uh it
includes e8 and uh he's mentioned
to include gs7 as well
this uh refusal covers gs5 e8
t2 and t9 of
the local plant of the current local
plan
so i'd like to propose that we refuse
planning permission
for this application on similar grounds
um and perhaps if we could add uh advice
before
i'll put that proposal on the last for a
second there and if we could have
uh some advice some advice from um
our planning officer on those actual
um on what reasons we could put in there
uh gs gs7 and e8 for sure
we understand that already as council uh
powell's explained but gs5 t2 and t9
could we have some advice on that please
uh from from
our plenty officer thank you i i second
emotion
um from listening to
uh a lot of uh contributions from
from um the public and from members i
think
it it seems to me as if it's a uh all
the elements that
are being raised combined to be a
um a adverse residential amenity
concern i think that um
whether that is in relation to
inconvenient parking whether that's in
relation to
additional traffic and and noise clearly
the county highway authority
are not identifying a um
a highway concern in the
in the parameters that they need to be
able to
advise on this issue but clearly what
with the noise
the disturbance the privacy the
cars coming and going the parking the
slamming of doors
whether it's within the hours or not
within the hours they all amount to
a combined issue in relation to um
concerns over adverse impact on
residential amenity and i think that um
all those issues rolled together um uh
provide a a single reason in relation to
um
the um in relation to the
residential amenity concerns as i say i
think that um
the the county highways have not raised
any objections
on on the um planning on the
highway terms that they would normally
need to
advise on and so it really does i think
come down to the combined
residential amenity if
i could just come back on that chair uh
that is the case yeah for sure
but on seven fern lee they also didn't
raise any concerns as well
uh highways so it's exactly the same
there
response from legal thank you
yeah i just wanted to advise not to
place too much reliance on the the
fernley
uh decision uh as you know each case has
to be taken on its own merits
so um just because uh
a an application a similar application
was refused doesn't mean
that you have to follow that um that
decision in this case
and there will be uh differences between
the fernley and
this case and those differences need
need to be taken into consideration so
for instance um
the ad firmly did they have the same
amount of parking as they they have in
this
this case what were the hours of
um what were the hours of of business on
the fernley was that similar to this or
was it
was it longer than what's proposed um
so as i say take take this on it's
um take this case on its merits and uh
don't just
blindly follow what you've uh what was
decided in on the fernley case
councillor foster yeah come back yeah
thanks for that uh
jim i appreciate that um i was just
asking questions on it and
if we concentrate therefore and then
what councilor powell
uh those concerns and what uh
uh richards uh mentioned the adverse
residential immunity content if we focus
on them with gs7
and e8 please so i'd like um
to propose that we do refuse it on those
grounds
so basically the motion is to refuse uh
the application on the grounds of the
adverse impact on residential immunity
perhaps hello uh
councillor regis do you apologize sir
sorry about that
uh just before we move to the boat i
just wanted to obviously make the point
if we are mindful of going down the
route of refusing
so obviously i know we want to take each
application on its merit so when i'm
when i'm considering application you
can't help but look at other
applications that have happened
either nearby or that you've experienced
before because you do
sort of want to to get a feel for it
i've experienced a business
being put at the end of just my
residential street
um you know and the concerns that were
raised around that with regards to very
similar
issues and now creating lots of problems
for residents in and around me so i do
have to consider that and you know when
you're talking about putting
a business in in the midst of a
residential street
um so obviously i know what everybody's
kind of saying which is why i thought if
we could have looked at putting imposing
some restrictions and how much
that would have helped really
okay so we still have the motion on and
i'll ask the clerk to read it so we've
got clarification
yes yeah essentially what it seems to be
suggesting is that planning
um permission be fused on the
application
on the grounds of its um impact or it's
had the adverse impact
on the residential immunity of the
community but the focus really being on
parking excess traffic noise
disturbance uh and uh the impact on
privacy
which you suggest could perhaps actually
then be sort of developed in detail uh
by the
um a.g planning along with yourself
chair in terms of
usual practice have i captured that
correctly
councillor foster
sorry about that uh could ask for yeah
uh that suits me could ask for counselor
powell's comments on that because he uh
he got more details on aired at the time
counselor pal yeah i would be happy with
that
um i think the the um the point that um
uh our planning officer has made about
the combined
adverse impact is is
is one that would be sufficient to be
honest
thank you councillor armitage
uh thank you chair i was also uh
uh policy sdc
12 covers everything i think
thank you are we ready to move to a vote
thank you chair um as per usual we'll be
going with
um a roll call vault um
if you could clearly vote for against or
abstain um alan would you just confirm
to the members what they'd be voting for
on i say essentially
uh what we just mentioned before that
this would be to reject
the officer recommendation to approve
planning permission
um on the grounds of the combined
impact on residential adverse impact on
residential immunity
focusing primarily parking traffic noise
disturbance and privacy a range of
points to be made then the suggestion is
is that as part of this
sort of decision if that's indeed the
decision that you take
that the uh a.d planning would actually
sort of finesse the actual arguments as
to sort of
for your rejection in consultation with
the chair
is that um as i say members is that um
essentially what your goes on yeah thank
you
thank you then through you um if members
could uh turn their microphones on at
the appropriate time and
um clearly say either for against or
abstain
council armitage councillor clough
oh councillor cooper
four councillor foster four
council heart sean
councillor huckabee
jones for liggett
four councillor powell four
cancer reader
four councillors
castle rough or councillor windley
four sure that's 13 votes for
zero against and zero abstentions
yeah so that means chair that the
motions passed
uh against officer recommendations the
application has been refused
thank you as we've been at it for just
two and a half hours would we like a
comfort break for 10 minutes
i've seen lots of nodding places right
can we please
be back by 25 to the very latest thank
you very much
yeah the live feed will continue so if
members would be kind enough to mute and
turn off their microphones
and their videos
back online now thank you
thank you everybody and the same rules
and motions etc
all carry on from our break
we've moved to the next application the
application number is
20 forward slash zero zero four three
five forward slash
fl h and this is the erection of a
detached garage in the rear garden for
storage of classic cars
at killer marsh have a presentation from
planning officer
we have the presentation coming up on
the screen here
um right we'll go first into the uh
um the first slide which is the
aerial view of the the site
of uh westfield hit um
where would you see these sites uh the
houses here have very long gardens
um you can see from the aerial picture
the application site in the
different in this sort of slightly
orange
shading uh to the
west there you'll see some uh um
glass houses and polytunnels you'll also
see other
um various
out buildings and other earth nadia from
other gardens and in the vicinity as
well
on to the next slide you'll see
well the same same again we'll move
straight on to the
um the proposal itself
you'll see that um at the front there
is the the house the house was um
has recently been um going through quite
a bit of uh
renovation um i dare say we'll even call
it uh
the changing from a bungalow into a
two-story house we'll see the
photographs of that um shortly
then halfway down the garden you'll see
a um a a gouge that is say
a three birth card which um
the applicant uh uses for his own um
everyday car and uh garden storage and
and things like that um and then the
proposal is for
this um uh larger three bay
um three car guard for his um classic
cars at the bottom of the
um the garden at the south side of the
garden
and you'll see it's um it's upper uh
it's really at the top of the garden at
the highest point in the garden
on to the next slide you'll see the um
the the building there it is a um
a large building uh
which you probably wouldn't think is uh
characteristic for a residential area
we'll look at the um wider issues in a
minute
but as you'll see it's a
a large square building with a single
roller shutter door at the front
um which would be um built out of blocks
and
and timber clad and with a profile cheat
roof
the next slide will
will lead you through the site um
with with photographs so this is the
um recently completed uh
new house that's uh a large germ
sort of dormer bungalow as opposed to
the bungalows
the bungalow that was there there are
other bungalows and other two-story
houses
in the vicinity and as we go into the
site
um coming down the side you see there's
a lot of uh
um external works still to be completed
as part of this
um uh house redevelopment um we go down
the side
of the house and come out to the other
end and you'll see there the um
they recently built um guards that was
also
uh granted consent in 2018 along with
the redevelopment of the house
you see the
[Music]
new fence on the left-hand side and the
um
uh the garden still needing to uh have
its
um landscaping completed having recently
received a
large pile of topsoil which may well
have come from the pile at the back
which we then will now see
so at the back let's say still a lot of
work going on but um where that
pile of topsoil currently is is where
the um this
proposed building this proposed triple
garage is going to go
um so we'll then take the next
slide and from here
you'll see this is the looking down the
the hedge on the
western side and you'll see there the
uh the the polytunnels and greenhouses
that are
along that side um and then
if you look on the next slide which is
just looking down from that same
position
down the um the garden back down towards
the garage in the house and you can see
the
um the house on the other side of the
fence there
um i think that's the uh that's
where one of the uh concerned residents
um
lives the
for this picture is taken um
from where that of the
um the the build in the proposed
building will
be located and then the next picture
is on the other side again from the
front of where that
building is being proposed
so you can see the distance it is
from the uh from the road you just about
see the roof of
the van parked at the front gate
which we saw as we entered the site
through these photographs
um so the
um the plan in history was that there
was um
a consent for a a bungalow in the back
here
not so long ago about five years ago but
that was never
pursued and um and then
the other two elements of planning
history relate to the
house and to the the garage that you can
see there
so really it's it's it's really quite a
simple matter
of whether um
the committee feels that the
uh size of this this building
is causing harm to residential immunity
or causing harm to the appearance
of the the area as seen from a new
public
vantage point there have been concerns
raised about uh loss of privacy but
um the
there'll be no greater loss of privacy
than anyone walking up
the um the garden without that building
they're looking back
across any houses or across any hedges
or
or fences the activity
in that building um would be the
basically the uh maintenance any
tinkering that
people carry out who are
classic car enthusiasts um
but it is all done as a uh at a hobby
level
so it's quite a simple uh um
decision to be taken is this harmful to
residential amenity
is this harmful to the appearance visual
appearance to the area
and our officer
recommendation here is that that
harm is not sufficient to
[Music]
recommend a refusal application which is
why we're recommending
that the commission is granted
thank you chad thank you
i believe we do have some speakers on
this
and we could go to the first one it's
the ward member no pots
good morning good morning
you three minutes and you'll get your 30
second prompt
okay thank you chair for allowing me to
speak on this
i wish to object as ward counselor to
this application um for the following
reasons
i believe this application would create
a space which would be out of character
with the other outdoor spaces to the
rear of properties on westark road
which are in the main green areas a
comparison has been made by the planning
officer between this application and the
outbuildings of the floristry business
to the other side of the application
site
i feel that this is an unfair comparison
the use of glass houses for growing
flowers does not generate the potential
nuisance
the story the garage for the storage and
maintenance of several vehicles could
the vehicles would need to be driven to
and from the site where there would be
additional noise generated in
association
with the maintenance activities of the
application
this surely has to be at odds with the
residential setting and would in turn
therefore
impact in a negative way on the
enjoyment and amenities surrounding
gardens
on west thorpe road han and heath avenue
incidentally this garage is actually
closer to certain properties
on heath avenue than to its direct
neighbors
in addition the application site is on
an incline which will elevate the
proposed building and therefore give it
further
visual prominence from the neighboring
dwelling at number 11
especially from the upstairs the
garage's proposed dimensions are huge
and i would question the necessity for a
garage of this size in a domestic
setting
especially one which is unattractive and
visually resembles an industrial unit
the plan shows three cars in the garage
but a building with dimensions of 11
meters by 11.5 metres by 5 meters
definitely has the capacity for an even
larger number of vehicles to be housed
there in the future
the drive to the access site was
directly adjacent to the property and
garden of number 11.
um if this application is permitted it
will be necessary to continue this hard
surface for the full extent of the
length of the garden
in effect they're putting a road
adjacent to the side of number 11's
garden
given that there is already garaging for
three vehicles and judging by the photos
submitted by a neighbor which is
shown on the planning portal but hasn't
been shown to you today
there are also non-domestic vehicles
parked there and the garden at number 13
appears to be
slowly morphing into a facility for
motor vehicles rather than a domestic
garden
i would therefore ask the committee to
reject this
application in its current form
[Music]
thank you thank you any questions
no questions chair thank you and we have
another speaker a katherine scott
okay hello you get three minutes with
the 30 seconds yeah wait a minute
because uh
start my video is that right okay can
you see me
yes okay right thank you uh hello
catherine scott neighbor at number 11.
i've lived in my home since 1990 having
lost my husband to a breakdown and
finally cancer
the garden has become a place of
reflection creativity
and energy a hobby deep in my soul
so how do i find myself thirty years
later
defending my right to peace light
unpolluted air in one third of an acre
stretching 70 meters from the nearest
road
when the huge benefits of a peaceful
garden to fitness
emotional and mental health are
headlines on everyone's agenda
during this unprecedented health crisis
to amplify my letter of objection
the dimensions of the building are
overbearing and the size of a house
will block sunlight from my garden and
allotments dominate my top boundary
and be difficult to screen it's grossly
excessive for the storage needs of three
old cars
it's like building a library for three
books then you add more
solution reduce dimensions to basic
minimum
with a flat roof in england nine percent
of household gap vehicles are garaged
six residential garages are superfluous
each classic car driven once a day
equates to 42
vehicles along my boundary in one week
plus the variety of vehicles around the
triple garage
and the towing trailers at my resume
visit
the drive becomes a fully functioning
highway
is this not a significant nuisance and
noise
i'm not convinced mr atarli stroke lay
will adhere to conditions when planning
is granted
and has shown little regard for
neighbours during his six-year project
and flouted planning permission to suit
his wishes
he built round part of the original
dwelling and then demolished it from the
inside
permission was to extend not new build
use pneumatic drills and similar
drilling tools constantly
seven days a week i became physically
ill
on medication for a year and unable to
be at home throughout the day
as the noise permeated inside even my
radio and high volume had to concede
delivery of scaffold up the garden at 7
15 a.m on a sunday
in november woke the young grandchildren
lockdown constant drilling one week
overruled any conversation with a
neighbor i asked politely if he could
minimize the name
and was verbally abused and slandered by
mrs lay
for objecting to any of their
applications
covet rules litter garden fire at 12
noon few communities live in isolation
of their neighbors
so consideration of the effects of their
choices with their outdoor space and
buildings erected
should be part of their plans my health
and quality of life are still being
diminished
one family's gain should not be several
families lost
it's time to thank you
are there any questions
thank you
are there any questions for the planning
officer not from me
no no oh sorry yeah that's true okay
these are questions directed to the
planning officer
uh legal yes yes so i just want to uh
advise members to disregard the the
final comments that um mrs scott
stated regarding the behaviour of the
applicant they are not relevant
uh considerations for in relation to
this planning application thank you
any questions for the planning officer
no questions chair wow thank you
i'll now offer the floor for debate
thank you chair um i have serious
concerns
about this development um
having only built a triple detached
garage
in 2018 here we are now looking at an
industrial unit effectively being built
in the garden
it it's it is an extremely large
development uh in the residential area
uh which actually backs onto uh east
avenue
and for me um
[Music]
i i would i would like to refuse it
under under 7.1
thank you are there any other comments
gosh counselor wendy's indicating
councillor wigley then councillor foster
thank you chair um i've got my concerns
about this
also um it states that
um not only are the garages
for and storing the classic cars but for
maintenance of the cars which
um i mean we all know you know
the noise and and the pollution that
cars can make
um and to have bats in a back garden
next to other people i don't
particularly like the idea of
and i think it needs uh really seriously
looking at
thank you councillor foster
yeah thanks for that chair i just
wondered does anybody know the reason
um why this is five meters high when
it's housing
classic cars uh it's not a garage height
five meters
is uh it's a huge height so do we know
if it's uh
how big these cars are going in
um if you want me to address
just that question very quickly um
all i know is that he has uh three
um 1970s classic cars that uh
he keeps there or he wants to keep
there and
why there would be the need for the
additional height
um i've got no um no answer to
um if if you wanted to
um i mean clearly this is the proposal
that's on the table and needs to be
determined um and as i said in my
presentation it's a
fairly straightforward question of um
uh is this causing visual harm to the
character of the area is this causing
residential amenity harm
and it's uh it will be a matter of uh
judgment as to whether or not you think
that harm is being created
thank you councillor armitage then
councillor reader
uh uh in uh uh answer to
uh council foster uh i have a friend
with uh with classic cars
and what he he's done he's actually put
a four poster lifting
uh and he has another one up on top
and that is uh i suspect
but it's uh conjecture really so
it was just an answer to that i do
believe
that the massing of this
uh proposal is you know completely out
of character
thank you counselor reader yeah i was
just gonna say a very similar thing i
think everybody's
um concerned quite about the size of the
building and what what the intentions
are with that can i just ask
obviously there's already a garage on
side
at the moment and i think i'm not sure
if it had
three doors or two doors is there any
particular reason why
the applicant doesn't feel that that
suits the needs of what he needs
i think the answer to that was passed
over earlier
he uses the original one at present
that's built
for family and garden refuse etc
this application is just to simply store
his classic cars
don't know if you want to come in on
that richard no
you're right there um there might
be a um
one of those vans that i saw at the
taking the pictures that you saw
on the um on the photographs might might
be his um as well
and uh that might be stored in in one of
them
from time to time i don't i don't know
but um
uh i would say it's um it's the
uh domestic vehicles possibly with that
ban as well
but i know councillor potts mentioned
that um
that's a
some sort of commercial vehicle was in
there so that may well be the van
i did see your hand go up i didn't see
the name oh
counselor you disappeared uh yeah i was
just uh
and i i do think it looks excessive for
the size of the area to balance them to
store just three cars
but um what's the actual construction of
this building going to be
i heard you mentioned timber
i think the um the report was setting
this up as being
uh block work with um the i think that
the
timber cladding around the um the upper
upper half of the building i think the
the the um
the plan was showing or the elevation
was showing
um we're showing that so it's a a
block um
concrete block building with a profile
tin
roof and with timber cladding on the
upper half of the elevations
and a roller shutter door
any other comments questions
counselor foster the
um in answer to the questions that we
have to ask ourselves uh
as our planning officers said is it
harmful to the residential area is it
harmful to the visual immunity for me
on both counts uh the answer is yes on
both of those
um and when we look at how this could be
refused
um and perhaps like to support uh what
uh councillor cliff
said uh but perhaps also add in not just
the h5
but gs5 and be1 for the reasons given in
7.1
that's it for her counselor club's a
reminder but something
thank you cancer club
yeah uh i'll i'd like to put forward a
motion to
to reject under those grounds
here we have
richard
it looks like we've frozen in time hello
helen hello can you hear me now
if
a puzzle and a second
to refuse applications
just one moment but obviously
uh we won't want to miss a vote on this
today i can confirm that we're having
some issues in the building at mill lane
in regard to bandwidth
um which is the reason why the live feed
has dropped out
um we're just going to rectify that
[Music]
wow
chair just confirming that the chamber
can hear me
you're back on mute so i'm just going to
ask you to mute
nikki can you hear me now i can the live
feed is back up and running
uh just wait for the chair to confirm
she's happy to continue
chair would you be happy to continue
that's fine nikki thank you just to
explain to anybody who's watching at
home we did have um a slight technical
issue
the meeting adjourned at the point where
the technical issue took place and we're
now back and running
thank you um alan we just need you to
go through the motion again because you
broke out okay then
right uh as i understand it then the
motion is to reject the application
uh on the grounds of the impact on uh
the cumulative impact on the residential
amenity of the neighboring area
essentially focusing on the sheer size
of the building
and its impact in terms of um sort of
track of traffic and sort of
ancillary issues is that the essence of
it
is there anything you'd like to add
there richard
i've got separate reasons one reason
being the impact on
residential amenity on
so on that basis chair that would be the
motion to reject
is everybody happy with that as the
fosters wishes to speak
can we look at 7.1 on page 31 where he
says policy be one of the adopted local
plan requires that new development
should respect the character and
appearance of the surrounding area
well it doesn't uh can we base it around
that
gs5 requires that the development should
not be detrimental to the character in
appearance of the site what it does can
we base it on that
and policy h5 requires that domestic
violence should be keep with the
property doesn't
so as um council clubs put
forward uh could we if council clubs
happy
could we include those three elements
and quote them as per seven point one
would council club be happy with that
i've really just given the two sort of
headlines in terms of um
uh uh visual appearance and residential
amenity
when we actually work up the detailed
wording of the um
of the reasons we would include
reference to to those particular
policies so
um so that that's a given that would we
would do that
they'd be worked up by the uh by richard
as uh ad planning
uh in consultation with the chair are
you happy with that counselor club
yes i'm happy with that thank you
we'll move to the vote then um
thank you chair so the vote on the table
is to
reject the application looking for a for
against or abstention on the vote
um if you could turn your microphones on
at the appropriate time and give
clearly which way you'd like to vote
councillor armitage
for councillor clough
paul councillor cooper
councillor foster sport
council heart sean
castle huckabee
councillor huckabee score
council jones or castle liggett
or casa powell
council reader paul
castle rouse cancer rough
and casa windley four that's 13 votes
for
zero against zero of sentence chair
therefore the rejection is carried
thank you thank you members and i think
that
brings us to a conclusion for this
morning's applications although
i'd like you to remain where you are
because we have a paper that's been
submitted
yes yeah i assume that there are masses
of urgency at this stage that you'd like
to take
nope i'm fine okay thank you
alan who's leading on this paper from
the governance team
um i think as the meeting's now closed i
think we just need to uh
close down the live feed is that in
place
uh yes chair martin would you stop
you